spider-man far from home follows a
literal class trip but it's also a head
trip and that goes for the characters in
the movie as well as its events some
characters play bigger roles unexpected
some aren't who they appear to be and
still others are a total surprise
here are some characters from spider-man
far from home with more meaning than you
realize
be warned spoilers are in thousand Li
coming as she doesn't homecoming Betty
brand first appears in the Midtown high
school news show and later she goes on
the trip with the rest of the class her
role is largely comic relief with her
sudden hyper close dating relationship
with Ned undercutting some tension it's
also her curiosity that lease Ned to
invent a night monkey the great
character find of 2019 what you might
not know is that Betty has a longer
history in comics as just about any
spider-man supporting character first
appearing an amazing spider-man issue
for in 1963 she and Pizza met as
employees of the tabloid newspaper The
Daily Bugle where she was publisher Jay
jonah Jameson secretary a role the
character also failed in the Sam Raimi
directed spider-man films comics Betty
even dated then married Ned leads both a
comics version of Ned doesn't share too
many similarities with the movie
incarnation comics Ned died and now
Betty is an investigative reporter
herself though Robert Downey jr. doesn't
have any scenes and far from home well
any new scenes he's in the bath
flashback Ironman hovers over everything
like the mark-5 armor obviously there's
his relationship with Peter which leads
to Peter being entrusted with Edith the
augmented reality system powered by Tony
Stark's glasses whose initial stands for
even dead on the hero there's also his
connection to Mysterio the big reveal
that Mysterio is a fraud in criminal
it's no surprise to comics fans but the
detail that Quintin Beck once worked for
Stark Industries creating the
hologrammatic therapy tour we see Tony
using Captain America Civil War is
totally new Plus 611 million dollars
from my little therapeutic experiment no
one in their right mind would have ever
funded it it's immediately toys Mysterio
into the MCU in a compelling way and
gives him something in common with the
vulture from spider-man homecoming
hatred of Tony Stark it's ironic that
Tony yelled at Peter for making messes
and homecoming but Peters have to clean
up Tony's messes twice now and Ironman
does technically appear at one point
rising out of Tony's grave in one of
Mysterio's illusions they
on the character design is a moment
that's a clear nod to the fans of the
Marvel Zombies comic series we've never
seen Peters Uncle Ben in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he's barely even been
mentioned Ben's violent death at the
hands of a name described the sthiti
Peter the tough lesson that with great
power comes great responsibility it's a
story that's already been told twice on
film in 2002 spider-man and again in
2012's the amazing spider-man
tourney Stark has filled the role of
Peter's father figure in the MCU but
Ben's presence is felt in Peters and age
humility and his deep down need to help
the little guy Peter carries his uncle's
lessons with him
he also carries a suitcase as Peter is
packing up to head off to Venice there's
a quick shot of a set of initials on
Peters luggage BFP for Benjamin Franklin
Parker it's the most overt reference to
Uncle Ben in an MCU movie yet not only
does blustery newsmen and Daily Bugle
publisher Jay jonah Jameson appear and
far from homesman credits scene after
spider-man gets framed for Mysterio's
crimes he's also played by the actor who
played him in the Sun Raimi spider-man
trilogy JK Simmons spider-man wasn't
attacking the city he was trying to save
it that's slander it is not I resent
that slander is spoken in print it's
libel
he looks a little different than he did
in the Raimi movies
Simmons naturally bald head is replaced
Comics accurate flattop he sported in
the earlier films but he's perfectly
Jonah in every other way stoking public
sentiment against spider-man and
painting the superhero as a threat or
maybe a menace
Jameson's appearance in the news report
that accompanies it that's a whole new
status quo for MCU spider-man going
forward in which he'll surely be
regarded with a lot more contempt from
the public and the anti spider squad be
far behind
once Mysterio's plan involving the
Holograms and drones has revealed the
audience has left a window and the Nick
Fury Maria Hill had been seeing have
been the real ones and when they've been
fakes generated by Mysterio stack
certainly it's worth passing the movie
to see when the two former shield
operatives are Holograms and when
they're nuts but even the real fury in
Hale aren't who they seem to be in the
post-credits scene it's revealed that
they've been Talos and Sauron the
husband and wife scroll leaders from
Captain Marvel the entire time furious
ask them to take his and hills place for
a bit or they relax on a virtual
vacation that is until Mysterio causes
all that chaos and Talos Astor call fury
to come back knowing
that recontextualizes every scene with
fury inhale and invites a second viewing
also sovereigns a pretty great shot with
a sniper huh though Mysterio builds them
up as hyper powerful mythological beings
the elementals are little more than a
trick of the lights they're realistic
projections emanating from the
holographic technology Quentin Beck
created as a Stark Industries employee
and the damage they do come from the
drones built by fellow ex-employee
William
but as Mysterio observes people believe
they're real in a postnup world because
they'll believe anything that's really
close to being believable for the comics
fans and the movie audience too because
three of them closely resemble the
spider-man villains Sandman hydro-man
and molten man at one point Flash
Thompson even reads a Wikipedia entry
for Morris bench the comics alter-ego of
Hydra man reciting a creation story that
pretty closely resembles hide romance
comics origin it clearly seems like a
fake-out directed at all the Hydra
maniacs watching Brad Davis who didn't
get snaps and therefore had five extra
years to grow up and get handsome serves
a role of Peters romantic rival Peters
so desperate to beat him out for MJ's
affection that he accidentally almost
kills him with a drone there was a
version of Brad who appeared in exactly
one comic issue 1979's amazing
spider-man issue 188 Mary Jane Watson
goes on a couple of dates with him while
on a break from dating Peter he's an
Empire State University football star
and kind of a jerk but he doesn't take
any pictures of anyone with their pants
down like the movie version does also
worth noting is Jason I&L oh who appears
once again as Betty brand's co-anchor on
the Midtown high news show was a
recurring character in the comic series
and told tales of spider-man he ran with
Flash Thompson and the group of other
popular teens often picking on poor
nerdy Peter Parker Dimitri appears to be
Quinton Becks right-hand man through
much of the first half of the movie
staying mostly silence while ferrying
Peter back to his Venice hotel and
driving the bus that takes her Midtown
high students to Prague we never quite
figure out what his deal isn't far from
home after the big reveal that Mysterio
has a whole team of former and bittered
Stark Industries employees working with
him Dimitri sort of just disappears from
the movie pre-release rumors pegged the
character as the Mitri Smerdyakov
also known as the chameleon one of
spider-man's oldest rivals
maybe he still could be someone had to
hand that doctored video over to the
Daily Bugle after all and like the
scrolls the chameleons can change his
appearance to look like anyone he
could be hiding in plain sight check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about spider-man
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]